AND HE GOES FROM CLEVELAND
TO NEW YORK,
AND HE'S LIKE, LET ME
TELL YOU ABOUT CHUCK BERRY.
LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT LITTLE RICHARD.
ABOUT FATS DOMINO.
AND HIS SHOW
IS PIPED TO EUROPE.
IT HAS BEEN SAID IT'S THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE BEATLES
HEAR ROCK AND ROLL,
IS ON ALAN FREED'S RADIO SHOW.
[bad British accent]
HEY, THERE, PAUL.
THIS IS PRETTY GOOD.
MAYBE WE SHOULD DO THIS.
[normal voice]
NEXT THING YOU KNOW,
IT'S, LIKE, THE BEATLES.
HE PUT TOGETHER A SHOW
IN BOSTON,
AND THE KIDS
ARE GETTING ROWDY,
AND THE COPS IN BOSTON,
THEY'RE LIKE,
NO, THIS IS NOT OKAY.
SO THEN ALAN FREED
GETS ONSTAGE,
AND HE'S LIKE,
KIDS, IT'S GONNA BE FUN.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A GOOD TIME.
WE'RE GONNA ROCK
AND ROLL TONIGHT.
ROCK AND ROLL,
ROCK AND ROLL, ROCK AND ROLL!
AND THEN THEY'RE LIKE,
EVERYONE,
WE'RE TURNING THE LIGHTS ON.
ALAN FREED MAKES
THIS OFFHAND REMARK.
HE'S LIKE, YOU KNOW,
I GUESS THE BOSTON COPS
JUST DON'T WANT YOU GUYS
TO HAVE ANY FUN.
IT BECOMES A TOTAL DISASTER,
BAD-NEWS THING.
IT'S, LIKE, ALMOST
A RIOT BREAKS OUT,
AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO SHUT THE THING DOWN.
OUTSIDE THE VENUE THAT NIGHT,
THERE WERE SOME STABBINGS,
AND THERE WAS SOME
VIOLENT [bleep] THAT WENT DOWN.
THEY ACCUSED HIM
OF INCITING A RIOT,
AND HE HAD TO DEFEND HIMSELF
AND SAY,
YOU KNOW, I DIDN'T DO--
I WAS JUST HAVING A CONCERT.
BUT HIS JOB,
HIS BOSSES AT W.I.N.S.,
WERE LIKE,
NO, THIS IS TOO CONTROVERSIAL.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THIS GUY IS--
CAN'T--GOT TO GO.
HE WENT ON THE AIR,
AND HE WAS LIKE,
LOOK, I'M SORRY.
I'M SAD.
BUT I'M GOING OFF THE AIR,
SO THANKS FOR ALL THESE YEARS,
BUT MY ERA IS OVER.
AND THEN HE PUT ON
THIS RECORD,
SO LONG BY FATS DOMINO.
IT WAS REALLY THE END
OF HIS REIGN AS THE GUY,
AND HE LEFT THE STATION.
- ♪ SO LONG
- AND WHEN HE GOES DOWN,
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE STATION,
ALL THESE FANS
ARE DOWN THERE,
AND THEY'RE LIKE,
OH, MY GOD, YOU CAN'T LEAVE!
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO?
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
WITHOUT YOU?
AND HE WAS LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME.
IT'S ABOUT ROCK AND ROLL.
AND ROCK AND ROLL
WILL ALWAYS BE HERE,
AND NOTHING WILL STOP THAT.
AND SO ROCK AND ROLL
WILL NEVER DIE,
AND ROCK AND ROLL
HAS GONE ON.
ROCK AND ROLL
IS BASICALLY ABOUT, LIKE,
GETTING UP THERE
AND BEING LIKE, [bleep] IT,
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
LIKE, IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SAY,
I DON'T GIVE A [bleep].
YOU HAVE TO [bleep]
SHOW IT.
[screams]